[موسيقى]
القاعده لو خلال 20 20
طيب
انا شخصيا لو قرات قريب في خمس دقائق احس
ان هي هتوجع
بشكل منها وباخر هنلاقي ان العالم كله كان
في فتره
كلنا مستنيين فرج ربنا اي امل ان الحياه
ترجع طبيعيه ثاني ده لو هنبقى فاكرين
الطبيعي اصلا
او مستنيين احتماليه
احتماليه وجود لقاح يخلصنا من الهم ده
احنا بسبب دي
احنا قدرت تبقى طبيعيه ثاني
اللقاح كان على قمه الحلول اللي اتعملنا
بيها مع خروج
القمه دي كانت جايه من عندنا من حضانه
7000 سنه
احنا وصلنا لقمه التعامل مع كرونا فلو
هنرجع بالزمن يبقى هنبدا منين من القاعه
وفي رحله الصعود دي حبه اطلب منكم نتخيل
ان احنا هنبني
هنعرف كويس قوي
اول مجموعه من الاحجار هنستخدمها هي
تطبيقا لمقوله لكل داء الدواء بمجرد ما
بشوف مشكله بشخصها المفروض تعالجها ازاي
دي اول طبقه في الهرم معي الا وهي
المعالجه باستخدام العقاقير او
اجدادنا كانوا يعرفوا اكبر قدر من
الاستفاده من الماده اللي قدامي
استخدام العصافير النباتات
في العصر الفرعوني استخدموا قشر الرمان
كماده قابضه لعلاج الحروق والجروح وبرده
استخدم كنبات لفرد الديدان وبعدين اكتشفنا
ان الماده الفعاله في قشر الرمان
اسال كمان وهو اليانسون
اليانسون بيكون بيخفف الالام الناتجه عن
مشاكل في الجهاز الهضمي وده بسبب ماده
اسمها انيسون وبرده اجدادنا استخدموه
وبكده نقدر نقول اللي زي اي ام مصريه
بتشرب منها ياسين لما يكون تعبان نفس الام
دي كانت بتعمل نفس كوبايه اليانسون
7000 سنه
او استخدام بشكل خارجي زي قطره او مرهم
العيون
هل ده كان اي كلام وخلاص
الحقيقه لا
الطب الحديث بيقول ان بعض الامراض في مصر
كان بيرجع سببها الناقص فيتامين ايه نمو
الاطفال كان بيتاثر بالنقص ده وساعتها
بيجي له نايت لايت او عمليا ولاقينا ان
الكبد كان من اغلى المصادر لغايه
ثانيه
علم الكيمياء او الكانستري لغويه جاي من
لفظ خيال
يعني فن التعامل مع المعادي بس لو هنرجع
بالزمن اكثر وبالرغم من الخلافه والاصل
الكلمه دي لغويه
فيني يعني الاسود اسم من اسامي مصر
القديمه وكنايه عن ارض مصر فيسبوك يعني
علم حاله اسمه جاي من اسم بلدك
طيب هل تطورنا في التعامل مع العقاقير
واقف هنا
لا لسه العصر الفرعوني وبنطق من العصر
اللي بعده العصر الاسلامي
مفهوم الصيدله على الممارسه الطب عموما
اول مدرسه لدراسه صيدله بغداد في القرن
التاسع وانتشار لان في انحاء الخلافه
ايه اللي حصل وقتها بقى
بالنسبه للتعامل مع العصافير كثير
ما حدش كان يعرف عنها حاجه واحنا
نستخدمناه زي الديناميكي والتمر الهندي
وبالنسبه للتفصيل كولجي او فكره التعامل
مع السلم والانتوت
فتفوقنا في تحسين تقنيات كيميائيه جديده
زي التقطير والتبخير والتركيب جابر بن
حيان في كتابها قدر في خلال ست فصول يحدد
السموم بانواعه واصلها وجرعتها
التسريح الجسم واثر السموم على الوظائف
الفسيول
وجيا ومجهودتنا
اكيد من خلالها
زي مثلا
دراسه العلم المتطوره خلت المكان اللي
وصلنا لها في علم الكيمياء العالم كله
طيب كده مبدئيا يا جماعه حمد لله على
السلامه
[موسيقى]
نصيب الجسم وتاثر على وظائفه في رحله
العلاج
بتاعكم كانت متقسمه ونصيب اول نصف واحنا
تكلمنا عنه قبل كده والنصف الثاني بيبقى
من خلال المعمل وطلب الشفاء من الاناء
وطبعا ده كان بيبقى في حلقه الوصل من
الكهنه
ومن هنا بنكتب جزء مهم في الحياه اليوميه
للمصري القديم غير انف او بيت الحياه
وده بيكون جزء مخصص من المعادن وفي بعض
الاحيان المستقل لدراسه وممارسه الطلبه
المدارس الطبيه زي ما بقال دلوقتي كانت
حاجه لها اسم مش بيدخلها غير القوم او
ابناء الاصدقاء وعشان تقدر تدرس علوم طبيه
لازم تنتهي الامتحانات كتير صعبه
ومن العصر الفرعوني
وبنوصل لفرنساوي
مكان تجمع المرضى بالفارسي وبالعربي
مستشفى مكان لطلب الشباك حلو قوي
الحجرات او الالوان كانت من اكثر التفاصيل
المبهره تقسيم المستشفيات احس ان المستشفى
ومساحات لطيفه مخصصه للمرضى النفسيين داخل
في حاله المرضى داخل المستشفى او
احد جاي من بره بقى او او
يتم استقباله في اوقات محدده من اليوم
وصرف الدواء له كل ده كان بيتم في صوره
مجانيه تماما حتى المرضى كانوا بعد ما
بيخرجوا وبعد ما بيتم شفائهم كانوا
بياخذوا فلوس
[موسيقى]
بعدها كمان
وبكده احنا خلصنا ثانيه طبقه من الهرم في
اول طبقه فهمت بقى ازاي
عمليه العلاج ازاي
[موسيقى]
ولكن
فين المجال التطوير ازاي تختبر نظريه
وبتاكد من صحتك
وبمعنى تاني لو معانا لقاح وعايز اتاكد
انه ام ادم العمليه دي اكيد لها قانون
كثير بتحركها
ودي ثالث طبقه معي
في العصر الفرعوني من خلال استخدام ادوات
بدائيه على نباتات زي نبات القمح والشير
يتاكده من نوع الجنين وجود الحمل ناشفه
[موسيقى]
او سوده
فعلا هرمونات الحمل بتكون هي السبب في نمو
النباتات
معلومه شبه دي البحث العلمي اخذ وقت طويل
على ما ادراك واحنا ادركناها من الملاحظه
والتجربه
وفي العصر الاسلامي خلفنا كثير من الفكر
اليوناني مش بمبدا هو كده ولكن بناء على
بحث وتجربه زي ابن الهيثم اللي صحح مفهوم
الرؤيه السائد والاقتناع من النور كان
بيخرج من العين وبينعكس فبنقدر نشوف
الحاجه واضحه
ومن الشغل خالد
هي مركز الكون من قبل منك يقت
رح ثانيه واحده
رؤيه شمس بتضحكي عليها ايه علاقه ده
بالهرم الطبي وكل الكلام اللي بيتقال
مبدا زي مبدا العين التجريبي او
الاكسبريمنتل ساينس لو طبقناه على فكره
تطوير اللي طاح من الاصل هنلاقي ان
المراحل اللي بيمر بها اي دواء هي هي
مراحل تكوين اي نظريه
في حاله النظريه ببدا ادور وابحث تكون
وجهه نظر وفي حاله الدواء ببدا ادور على
ماده فعاله يقول لها اثر جديد وبعد كده
ابدا اختبر نظري سواء صحيحه او لا وفي
حاله الدواء ببدا اجربه على حيوانات في
الاول وبعد كده المتطوعين البشر
قولنا ان اللفاح اكس ده في المرحله
الثانيه اه لا ده في المرحله الثالثه
ياه يعني بناء على مبدا عين بسيط طبقه
اجدادنا صح وكان رواد فيه قالت له في
الاخر يوصل البرسيم
كده احنا وصلنا لقمه النهارده
كله تمام
هو احنا هنرجع لحضرتك
انا كنت مخبيه عليكم انهم مش ثلاث طبقات
هم اربعه بس الرابعه
[موسيقى]
رابع طبقه طريقه توثيق السليم
في البرديات الفرعونيه قدرت توصل كل
المعلومات اللي بنقدر نوصلها زي بعضه
تكلمه عن الام
وحتى الكلمات السحريه اللي كانوا مقتنعين
انها بتساعد على الشفايف والمعلومات
الفنيه كلها كانت لابقه وقتها يعني في
خلال العصور المظلمه في اوروبا
ورديه كانت بتنصح ابناء مصر بالنظافه
الشخصيه وغسل اليدين تجنبها
العصر الاسلامي قدرنا نوثق المركبات اللي
بنوصل لها من خلال اقرب ذلك
وده بيكون كتاب شامل للمركبات بانواعها
واصلها وخصائصها وجرعتها
وفكره اننا نقدر نوصل المعلومات
ولان لكل رحله كنز في نهايه رحلتنا هو فين
الكنز ده بقى
هل ممكن الجنس يكون المجرد وجهه نظرنا
تتغير عن احداث عيشناها خلال السنتين اللي
فاتت
كل طبقه بينناها من الهرم كانت شبه مساحه
سري واصل من اجنبي
[موسيقى]
او طريقه التنسيق السليمه اللي وصلتنا
للوضع الحالي واللي من كارت صغير اقدر
احدد الشخص اللي قدامي ده اخذ جرعات اللي
تحت كامله ولا لا
شويه
ان النجاح كانت من الحاضر قدرنا نواجه
جائزه خروج
بس النجده بدايتها كانت من الماضي واللي
في النهايه الماضي هو اللي انقذ اصحابه
[تصفيق]